herzlich willkommen zurück bei german
wir sind heute in new york
er ist machen wir eine vierwöchige usa
reise und das ist unsere erste station
bei uns sind easy easy hallo hallo unser
übersetzer und mara heimat
woher kommst du ich komme aus kann zu
weniger aber ich studiere an juni in new
york und wie kommt es dass du so gut
deutsch spricht
ich lerne deutsch 4 1 sehr gut und wir
vier wir gehen damit man durch new york
und suchen dabei deutsche wir wollen
interviews machen erfahren dass die
menschen hier machen
mal sehen wir sie auf dem weg treffen
losgeht
ja wir haben jetzt gerade hier vier
deutsche tropfen am time square sie
haben sich dadurch verraten dass sie
deutsch gesprochen haben wo kommt ihr
denn her
in bielefeld und wie lange seid ihr
schon in den usa gestern angereist
eben gerade aus dem hotel direkt wieder
gekommen ein perfektes ja witzig so wie
wir quasi wo kommt der denn her
schwarzwald ja ich bin aus der nähe von
nürnberg wir machen hier eine woche
urlaub und waren gerade auf der weg auf
der suche nach einem picknickplatz wir
kommen aus berlin sind sehr zuerst ich
ja aber mein mann war schon häufiger ihr
seid ihr zum ersten mal hier
ich war hier per deutsche gelebt wir
sind jetzt die vierte woche hier also
new york erst ein paar tage sind schon
seit fast vier wochen in amerika wir
haben tagesplanung gemacht haben uns gut
überlegt was wir uns anschauen wollen um
möglichst vielen in den tag zu kriegen
und die zeit auch sinnvoll zu nutzen
richtig touristen die so abhaken alle
dass das das muss alles angucken so
sieht es aus wie man sieht bin ich von
klein auf new yorks seitdem ich denken
kann
naja ist das ein traum der sich erfüllt
hat es ist so wie es erwartet hat king
kong fehlt irgendwie state building
erwartet ja irgendwie schon ist es
permanent hier halligalli ist es
permanent laut ich war am ersten tag
maßlos irritiert selbst als ich das
hotelzimmer fenster zugemacht hatte war
es immer noch laut mittlerweile habe ich
mich daran gewöhnt er sein war
interessant zu sehen
die ganzen stellen die
sehenswürdigkeiten die man aus dem film
kennt und dass man das dann mit den
eigenen augen sieht
ich selber realisieren doch gar nicht
dass ich hier bin das ist schon ein
komisches gefühl
für uns war sehr überraschend eine
kleine private wahl umfrage gestartet
und wollten wissen wer wählt wien und
weil wir sind ja nun kurz im kurz vorher
war hier und wir haben festgestellt
werden fast nur trank wähler getroffen
was uns ziemlich erschreckt hat
angesprochen auf der straße auf dem
campingplatz drüber waren oder wenn wir
in der schlange stand die meisten haben
das sofort erzählt also gerade die die
eben nicht trump will die haben sofort
erzählt das waren weniger als die tram
trick wir hatten schon ein spannendes
highlight wir hatten das duell trump
gegen hilton hillary clinton das war das
war spannend ja dass wir abends in der
kneipe das haben wir geguckt ja und ohne
dass sie jetzt die kandidaten bewertet
wie läuft das ab im vergleich zu wie in
deutschland politik funktioniert hat an
vielen stellen der sachbezug gefehlt es
war durchaus amüsant es war
spannend zu hören was hillary für ein
maßloser hass in ihrem herzen trägt laut
trump aber es der politische sachbezug
heute an vielen stellen schon gefehlt
deutschland wäre schon ein bisschen
weniger emotional viel weniger emotional
in deutschland weiß nicht mal einer dass
angela merkel den man hat also das
interessiert auch kein was sie macht die
politik unsere nächste station in new
york ist die united nations
international school und will man gerade
eingeladen bei frank du bist
deutschlehrer hier richtig genau ich bin
deutsch leer aus weil bei etwas mehr als
heuer anna yunus wie ist das hier in
deutsch zu unterrichten
ja es ist einerseits wirklich
interessant an dieser schule vor allem
ich weiß gar nicht für ganz new york
kann ich sagen aber an dieser schule
weil sehr internationales und wir haben
schüler aus über 100 ländern die auch
ganz unterschiedliche muttersprachen
mitbringen so dass es einfach furchtbar
spannend es in der klasse auch was für
themen und diskussionen hochkommen das
macht es spannend aber sprache lernt ist
natürlich sprachen lernen wir kurz eine
präsentation gemacht und haben matthias
getroffen matthias woher kommst du aus
österreich und den niederlanden also
mein vater österreicher mutter freuen
dich wie ist es in new york zu leben was
mike stone new york also in new york zu
leben ist schon sehr spannend ich meine
jeden tag muss ich lebe in new york ist
doch wirklich toll um mir zu leben und
es ist ja es ist hektisch ist manchmal
stress manchmal denke ich will am
liebsten in einer kleinen im kleinen
dorf in österreich seien aber ja in jork
ist immer immer was zu tun und überaus
zu erleben was ist der größte
unterschied für dich zwischen
österreichern und amerikanern also die
österreicher die sind in der regel nicht
so offen oder freundlich wie die
amerikaner
ich weiß nicht ob mein amerika ist
manchmal schwierig zu sehen ob das jetzt
wirklich ein echtes freundlich sein ist
oder eher oberflächlich aber generell
ist es angenehmer um mit amerikanern
umzugehen vor allem mit welchem man
nicht kennt also
es ist vielleicht leichter um leute
kennenzulernen amerika jedenfalls die
leute jetzt sind wir auf der staten
island ferry und bei mir sind bar von
easy hallo hallo ist einer unserer
zuschauer und wohnt in new york im juni
hat er uns in berlin besucht und als er
gehört hat dass wir in die usa kommen
hat er uns eingeladen
ja das stimmt und das ist der wahnsinn
weil bob ist tatsächlich für fünf tage
aus seinem eigenen appartement
ausgezogen damit wir dort holen können
dann möchten wir die gelegenheit nutzen
einfach mal danke sagen
willkommen zu hause
ja wir haben uns jetzt hier im central
park mit petrina engelke getroffen und
sie ist bloggerin und autorin aus
deutschland wohnt aber in new york
petrina erst mal warum wir uns in new
york wegen new york das alles ich habe
nirgendwo mehr geschichten gefunden als
in dieser stadt und gleich vom
geschichtenerzählen lebe war das
irgendwie ein logischer schritt dahin zu
ziehen ist new york typisch amerikanisch
das glaub ich nicht also ich hab mehr
viel mehr zeit in new york verbracht als
in anderen gegenden in amerika ich habe
auch nie anders
anderswo als in new york und in
deutschland gelebt insofern weiß ich
nicht ob ich die beste expertin für
diese frage ist aber ich habe den
eindruck new york ist anders das ist so
ein bisschen wie das der vatikan ist
nicht italien oder dass wir jetzt einen
ganz krasses beispiel aber new york ist
schon sehr speziell was ich zum teil auf
die insellage zurückziehen
warum wenn du auf einer insel lebt dann
kannst oder wenn eine stadt auf einer
insel angesiedelt ist kann sie sich
nicht ausbreiten
sie kann da ist eine natürliche grenze
das heißt die vororte es gibt vor orte
die auf dem festland sind die werden
aber nicht so wirklich ernst genommen
und sind nicht richtig new york und wer
hier ist muss halt dann mit der dichte
klarkommen und viele entwicklungen
gesellschaftlicher art politischer art
in umweltbezogene cetera pp zeigen sich
hier meiner ansicht nach viel schneller
als wenn du durch eine lupe auf einer
gesellschaft lux als in anderen gegenden
des landes oder auch vielleicht in der
welt
ja liebe leute jetzt sind wir mitten in
new york vor den deutschen haus der new
york university und bei uns ist juliane
kämpfe die direktorin
juliane was wir von dir wissen wollen
ist ist deutsch eine populäre sprache in
den usa das kommt darauf an wo man
hingeht in den usa also hier in new york
denke ich ist es relativ populär wenn
man in andere städte geht es
wahrscheinlich eher spanisch oder
mandarin angesagt wer kommt zu euch zu
uns kommen leute die aus würde ich sagen
drei großen gründen deutsch lernen
wollen
das ist die karriere der tourismus und
die liebe wir sind die menschen hier so
drauf in new york spannend sehr
hilfsbereit für einen deutschen fast an
mancher stelle zu viel service weil man
das gar nicht gewöhnt ist
ja ich finde die amerikaner sind sehr
viel freundlicher als die deutschen also
auf den straßen
die fragen dich kann ich ihnen helfen
suchen sie in deutschland muss man
fragen können sie mir helfen bitte wir
haben gestern abend ein eis gekauft und
der freundliche mensch hinter dem tresen
fragt braucht den löffel für das eis und
ja das war super weil wir hatten keinen
doppel auf dem hotelzimmer und in
deutschland würde sowas nicht keiner
gefragt was mich natürlich interessiert
ist die perspektive einer deutschen die
seit 19 jahren in den usa lebt
das ist der große unterschied zwischen
den deutschen und den amerikanern das
ist die gretchenfrage da muss ich habe
aufpassen
das ist man kann das nur sehr
verallgemeinern und verallgemeinerungen
sind auch wieder gefährlich
grundsätzlich würde ich sagen die
amerikaner sind nach wie vor eher offene
und die deutschen sind grundsätzlicher
immer noch eher so ein bisschen
skeptischer aber ich glaube die
deutschen verbessern sich
liebe leute das german aus new york
unsere erste episode aus new york und
hat sie gefallen sie hier
es war fantastisch stadt zum abschluss
dank an bord super super nett als
nächstes fangen nach washington seid
gespannt auf die nächste episode und
wenn ihr uns folgen wollt auf unserem
trip durch die usa dann unbedingt
facebook und instagram gruppen dort
täglich fotos videos und kleine updates
danke fürs zuschauen wenn ihr sie
germans supporten möchtet dann zittert
schon in der hand wenn ihr sie gerne
unterstützen möchtest dann werdet ein
patch für uns wir freuen uns sehr
darüber und substrat diese lärm in
schuss und bis zum nächsten mal